Passover of course the holiday that
celebrates the freedom of the Jewish
people from their bondage in Egypt well
we have a special Passover tradition
here at our show so once again ladies
and gentlemen it's time for our annual
throwing of a pharaoh through a giant
wall of matzah let's bring it out boys
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you can see Andy at great expense we
have had a wall of matzah
I love matzah and they'll and I last
year it worked out we got lucky and you
found a guy dressed as a pharaoh in the
audience but there is just no possible
way that that could possibly look happen
again I know the odds are against it
it's unlikely but let's try it Billy do
me a favor would you please scan the
audience let's see if there's anybody
anybody at all great I stand corrected
now that guy's great another one yeah no
no no I'm just I'm I'm totally just here
to see the show security help us out
here would ya
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very nice these guys play bar
mitzvahs all right Pharaoh this is the
tradition on the show are you going to
let my people go
I'm not a pharaoh I'm just an extra in
the new Mel Gibson Bible pick it's
shooting here today okay I don't care
what your Excuse is I'm gonna ask you
again are you going to let my people go
I'm Jewish my name is David blonde Steen
I don't care trouble you have a drum
roll please
no no no no please stop stop please stop
Conan please don't you understand that
Passover is about freedom from tyranny
and not just for the Jews of ancient
Egypt but for the people today as well
for all people regardless of their race
their religion their ethnic origin or
sexual orientation we are all just
brothers and sisters Conan all of us and
some of us
some of us are living in bondage bondage
every bit as bitter as that felt like
yeah that's really nice but screw that
who wants to see Pharaoh go through them
[Applause]
Oh
Happy Passover
[Applause]
you